[Musique]
blandine r ça va commencer
la machine
en ce sens la gare d'arras
[Musique]
des journaux tels journal là monsieur
patrick gens voudraient bien voilà
bonjour mais si vous permettez ce n'est
pas pour le dire du moins pas tout de
suite très simplement vous montrer
comment on peut réaliser une poupée en
papier avec une simple feuille de
journal est un peu d'imagination de près
en papier jeu tu me poupée géante là on
a zappé deux poupées hier que non non
non toujours une seule des plus petits
et maintenant holala pitié devant moi je
veux bien alors des noms comme sa caisse
en grappe le pied l'édifice il rate un
truc aujourd'hui alors cela devient
difficile à 2,7 et la déchirer je viens
ici encore mal an ce sera vraiment la
dernière fois parce que là votre tout
petit petit gars on l'a on va essayer
comme ça leur attention abracadabra et
maintenant peut-être un petit geste et
tous les morceaux
qu'est ce qu'ils pensent voilà je ne
comprends rien du tout la feuille et
revenez entière comme au départ mais
rate un truc pour montage interne car il
manque quelque chose
vais voir et voir fait voir dans ta
bouche prévoir fait voir
noah salle j dont c'est la dernière fois
que tu me fais des blagues de genre un
regard abbassian cette immersion
[Musique]
mais qui
la pause
japonais
comment
[Musique]
non
je
où
[Musique]
donnez moi votre avis
ah ouais
it is more du numéro tellement de bonnes
et on peut demander une personne
[Musique]
en
vous
[Musique]
oh
c'est peut-être une netteté marquez
capitaine guy forget pense que c est l
intérieur pour moi vous êtes quand même
terrible vous vous ouvrez m'envoyer il
voulait savoir c'est un taux si un truc
mais on vient de malabo et c'est parce
que c'est un ami avoir trouvé me faire
connaître ce tour ça donne quoi
c'est un tout qui suit avec des petits
cartons de couleurs variées rouge vert
jaune bleu rien angle d'accord au
boitier je vais vous le faire un pascal
un garde voilà les cartons tu vas mettre
un carton celui que tu veux dans l'
enveloppe par exemple sur nothing bien
fermé l'enveloppent et tu caches les
trois autres cartons derrière la table
pour que je ne vois pas d'accord après
turin ce qui va se passer
évidemment je ne regarde pas c'est
promis dire je vais regarder alberto
dans les yeux pour pas trop cher si je
le surveille vase autre que chairman
regard de makira oui
regarde moi je ne triche pas gérard oui
tu louche non je n en garde pas sur tout
et non non non alors pascal c'est
jacques un je ne sais pas je ne vois pas
mais j'espère que tu as bien mis un
carton dans une enveloppe et cacher les
trois heures ça vient de franchir un bon
jeu pour dérouler à aa
ça y est alors maintenant attention je
prends l'enveloppent je fais juste de
sur un petit mouvement abracadabra c'est
le bleu que tu as mis dans l'ambiance
c'est exact vérifiez d'ailleurs tu as
bien fermé l'angle 1 voilà le bleu
exacte et tu peux moindre les autres
c'est tout voilà on m'a alors là gérard
ya sûrement un truc
écoutez si vous regarder de très près
oui ici dans le timbre vous pourrez
remarquer un tout petit truc que j'ai
fait à l'aide d'une pointe de ciseaux
esprit critique mythe
non c'est vrai mais là ce qui fait qu'à
travers ce petit trou on peut voir la
couleur des cartons et pour que vous
puissiez mieux vous rendre compte je
vous montre maintenant pourquoi d'une
enveloppe géantes et vous allez voir si
jamais le carton rouge à l'intérieur
vous voyez dans le petit trou le rouge
et le rouge
je met maintenant la place du rouge le
vert
à l'intérieur on voit le vert profitons
si je met maintenant le bleu est bien
c'est pareil on voit le bleu voilà alors
évidemment il faut pas trop montrer une
enveloppe et le faire d'une façon très
décontractée comme ça on ne voit pas
mais dans un timbre ça ne se remarque
pas je crois que tu as une version qui
m'amuse beaucoup de façons de présenter
qu'ils me tuent veut montrer ce qui est
fait le succès comme si on n'avait rien
vu un bon troisième vous dire tout de
suite je suis un grand astronome
cinglante astronomes appellent charles
d'habitude ici ont atteint james mais
d'habitude je m'appelle charme
charlatans c'est un programme
alors je vais vous présenter mes quatre
planètes préféré le soleil en journée
oui jupiter en rouge saturne mois venus
en blouse j'aiderai jolie matin je vais
demander à une personne de vous 4 à
gérard j'ai suivi l'accord agir agir
avoir encore moyen de mettre une de ces
quatre planètes dans mon enveloppe
magique de refermer la boîte à l es tu
ne regarde pas je ne triche pas je suis
inquiet ainsi que sur magna rien dire
voilà et puis on va cacher les autres
planètes
ça donne envie de voyager de cadres et
danois
faut bien les cacher oui je me retourne
et je vais demander à girard d'après lui
qu'est ce que c'est que ça au sein
bidule un carton habitués ça vous avez
insulté mon canap outre la musique
à croire qu'à la poudre sa musique un
cada falls il se déplie regardez c'est
un nouvel engin que je viens d'inventer
en turquie dans la zone pour l'inventer
c'est un appareil spécial pour traverser
les murs les portes et surtout les
enveloppes
eh bien c'est faux je vais voir j'aime
ça marche oui je vais fixer leurs cannes
à puta musique et je vais régler la
distance
ça y est je regarde bien à gilles qui
chauffe
ah oui mais forcément avec ce truc ça
brûle assez brave titre en jeu leur
chaude
c'est exact je crois que c'est le soleil
si c'est exact
aveugle il a trouvé sa déroute plein
soleil
alors les avez vous souvenez quand même
pour ce faire cette offre des cartes on
pouvait dessiner ce que voulait dessus
il faut une enveloppe mais on allait
oublier
il faut aussi des timbres et oui alors
les timbres si vous pouvez vous amuser
quand vous avez des terrains faire un
petit tour avec regardez vous prenez un
album de table pays vide
ah ben oui il évident parce que
évidemment je vous leur montrez
revêtement il n'a pas encore que les
tables rondes à cordes accordé alors
maintenant vous prenez les timbres et là
vous essayez de les placer tous à
l'intérieur on voit qu super être très
pratique voyez tous les timbres et
maxime temps on voulait rajouter voilà
vous lui mettez n'importe comment sur la
fin d'importance vous faites
abracadabra c'est certes important a
pris aussitôt regardé par magie tous les
timbres se retrouve exactement coller
comme il le faut aucun album soit joli
et agréable
et bien voilà donc maintenant vous avez
tout compris enfin presque tous mais
heureusement on est un petit peu triste
r1j investir la silicone
[Musique]
[Musique]
rafika tête oui
on
j
oh
tout beau
et
[Musique]
donc
on
[Musique]
le
on
[Musique]
à l'approché droits
là
à
[Musique]